dijo que Taiwán era un gran amigo y que
este encuentro una posibilidad para
seguir estrechando Los lazos económicos
Los lazos por la paz y por la democracia
por su parte la presidenta de Taiwán
Pues dijo que este encuentro
precisamente le reafirmaba al pueblo de
Taiwán que no están aislados en su
defensa por la soberanía que no están
aislados y que tienen a un amigo como
Estados Unidos hay que Resaltar también
que precisamente cuando se daba este
encuentro a las afueras de esta
biblioteca donde se llevó a cabo el
encuentro estaban carros con pancartas
apoyando a Taiwán que decían sin embargo
al mismo tiempo un avión sobrevolaba con
una pancarta grande que promovía la
política de una sola china que es lo que
quiere Beijing una sola China y
desconociendo la soberanía de Taiwán es
que esta situación había provocado
yatenciones entre Estados Unidos y China
cómo ha respondido Beijing a este
encuentro
exactamente recordemos que la antigua
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi había
viajado así apenas unos meses a Taiwán
Esto llevó a que a muchos analistas
dijeran que después de esa visita de
Nancy pelosi las relaciones entre China
y Estados Unidos llegarán a su peor
punto desde 1979 el la portavoz de la
embajada de China acá en Washington ha
dicho que precisamente esta reunión
entre el líder de la cámara de
representantes y la presidenta de Taiwán
podían llevar a una confrontación aún
peor entre Estados Unidos y China por su
parte el Ministerio de relaciones
exteriores chino dijo que seguía muy de
cerca el desarrollo de esta reunión y
que iban a seguir defendiendo la
soberanía de China y la política de una
china desde